>> ♪ ♪
>> [CHEERING].
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: HAPPY TUESDAY.
GREAT TO BE IN NASHVILLE.
WE HAVE SOME GREAT GUESTS.
JUDGE JEANINE IS HERE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> SHAY DROVE ALL THE WAY FROM
NEW YORK.
HERE SHE IS PULLING INTO THE
PARKING LOT.E DROVE ALL THE WAY
NEW YORK.
HERE SHE IS PULLING INTO THE
PARKING LOT.
[LAUGHING].
>> Greg: I ASKED HER WHY.
SHE SAID I TREAT THE ROAD LIKE
LET'S DEATH ROW.
PUT ON THE SEAT BELT AND STEP ON
THE GAS.
AND LARRY GATLIN FROM THE GATLIN
BROTHERS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: THOSE GUYS PARTIED BACK
IN THE DAY.
THEY INHALED MORE WHITE POWDER
THAN A BABY'S BUTT.
THEY WERE A WILD BUNCH BACK IN
THE '70s.
NOW THEY FOR THEIR 70s.
[LAUGHING].
NOW THEY CUT THEIR COKE IS
LIPITOR.
THEY REPLACED PROSTITUTES WITH
PROCTOLOGISTS.
LARRY IS KNOWN FOR THE HIT ALL
THE GOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF THE GOLD IN CALIFORNIA.
LARRY SHOULD UPDATE THE SONG TO
REFLECT TODAY.
ALL OF THE POOP ON MY SHOE IN
CALIFORNIA.
IT'S FILTHIER THAN KAT'S
VOCABULARY.
CALIFORNIA DREAMING IS GUY
THROWING UP ON YOUR PORCH.
A SHOUT OUT TO SEAN PENN.
KAT HAD A GREAT FIRST NIGHT OUT
IN NASHVILLE.
>> YEAH!
>> YOU ARE SWEET.
>> ♪ ♪
.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: I TELL HER TO HOLDBACK.
IT'S ONLY MONDAY.
RIGHT, I WILL SHAVE THE REST OF
THIS MOON SHINE FOR MY CEREAL.
I WILL JUST MOVE ON.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: REMEMBER WHEN WE WERE
TOLD THE ADULTS WERE TAKING BACK
GOVERNMENT WHEN JOE BIDEN WON.
THEY OUSTED ORANGE GODZILLA AND
WE GOT THE CREATURE AT ANY RATE
BLACK LAGOON.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: AMAZING.
THERE IS SERIOUS BEDLAM AT THE
BORDER.
MANY ARE SICK.
AND LIKE HILLARY CLINTON CRIME
REMAINS UNCHECKED AND
UNPROSECUTED.
AMERICANS REMAIN IN AFGHANISTAN
AND CRIME IS RAISING LIKE HUNTER
BIDEN'S PULLING ON A CRACK PIPE.
I STILL LOOK GREAT.
IT'S AMAZING FOR A MAN IN HIS
EARLY 40s.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: IT'S NOT THAT FUNNY,
JUDGE.
DESPITE ALL OF THIS BAD NEWS WE
HAVE AN ADULT IN CHARGE, IN AN
ADULT DIAPER.
CAPTAIN JOE.
LOOK AT HIM.
AVIATOR SUNGLASSES, BOMBER
JACKET.
TOO BAD HIS MICROPHONE GETS CUT
MORE THAN ME TRYING TO MAKE THE
8th GRADE SOCCER TEAM AM THIS
YEAR I WAS CLOSER THAN EVER.
SERIOUSLY, I FEEL LIKE A GUEST
AT EPSTEIN'S ISLAND.
WHERE ARE THE ADULTS.
I WAS TOLD IN MY ANGER
MANAGEMENT CLASSES THAT AN ADULT
TAKES RESPONSIBILITY FOR HIS
ACTIONS.
HERE IS JOE RESPONDING TO THE
RECENT CRISIS.
>> LOOK AT WHAT I INHERITED WHEN
I CAME INTO OFFICE.
THE STATE OF AFFAIRS AND WHERE
WE WERE.
WE HAD NO PLAN.
I COULD GO DOWN THE LIST.
I AM NOT COMPLAINING.
IT'S JUST A REALITY.
>> Greg: IT'S JUST A REALITY.
THIS GUY WOULD NOT RECOGNIZE
REALITY IS THE ENTIRE CAST OF
DUCK DYNASTY BIT HIM IN THE ASS
WHEN I WOULD PAY FOR.
ANYONE VACCINATED TODAY CAN
THANK OPERATION WARP SPEED
CREATED BY TRUMP.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: BIDEN'S REALITY
BLAMEERN FOR EVERY MISTAKE YOU
MAKE WANT NOT ONLY BLAME THE
LAST GUY IN OFFICE BUT THE
DESCENT AMERICANS LIKE THE GUY
TRYING TO STEER HIS HORSE.
JOE BIDEN PUNISHING THE BORDER
PATROL FOR PATROLLING THE
BORDER.
WHAT IS NEXT PUNISH STRIPPERS
FOR STRIPPING?
THE POLICE FOR POLICING?
WAIT, WE ALREADY DO THAT IT.
PEOPLE DOING THEIR JOBS ARE
BEING PUNISHED BY PEOPLE WHO
DON'T.
YOU HAVE AN INCOMPETENT
PRESIDENT CLEANING UP HIS
MISTAKE AT THE BORDER AND THE
MEDIA DEMONIZING THE COPS.
AND THE MEDIA STILL WHINES ABOUT
USING FORCES TO NAVGATE UNEVEN
TERRAIN.
WHAT SHOULD THEY USE?
SEGWAYS?
WHY IS THE BORDER PATROL NEEDED?
BECAUSE THERE IS NO WALL.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> I RESPECT JOE IF HE ADHITS HE
WRONG HE SMEARS THAT GUY AND
APOLOGIZEDED.
I WON'T HOLD MY BREATH BECAUSE I
WOULD LOOK LIKE A SMURF.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: BUILD BACK BETTER.
SOUNDS LIKE A LEFT OVER FROM
A LABORED SALE AT HOME DEPOT.
THE ONLY THING JOE BUILD IS
BLAME.
HE PASSES MORE BUCKS THAN A GUY
WHO IT'S DOLLAR BILLS.
I WONDER IF BLAMING THE PAST
WORKS IN REAL LIFE.
>> THIS PLACE IS SUCH A MESS.
I AM SO SICK OF THIS.
>> STOP BLAMING ME.
IT'S YOUR EX.
>> THERE IS NEVER ANY FOOD IN
THE FRIDGE.
YOU ARE A SLOP.
>> IT'S YOUR EX.
>> STOP BLAMING MYEX FOR
EVERYTHING.
>> RIGHT OVER THERE.
>> LEAVE HIM ALONE AM WE ARE
THIS IT LOVE.
>> ♪ ♪
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: THAT SHOULD BE
A SITCOM.
WHAT IS JOE SAYING FOR HIMSELF.
>> COME ON, MAN, DON'T GIVE ME
THAT ABSENT LEADERSHIP.
I AM PRESENT AND ACCOUNTED FOR.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE I AM RIGHT
NOW ACTUALLY.
THEY DRIVE ME PLACES AND I GET
OUT AND READ WHAT THEY TELL ME.
THEN NO QUESTIONS.
NO QUESTIONS.
THEN I GET BACK IN THE CAR.
THEY DRIVE ME SOMEPLACE ELSE.
IT WORKS OUT, MAN.
WHOOPS, IT JUST GOT DARK.
I KNOW WHERE I AM.
>> [LAUGHING].
GREG THE GOOD NEWS ABOUT AMERICA
THIS COUNTRY IS SO STRONG WE CAN
STAND AN OLD MAN WHO REFUSES TO
BEAR ANY RESPONSIBILITY.
CAN WE ENDURE THE WOKESTERS WHO
CONTROL HIM IN LIKE KIDS GOING
AFTER THE RICH'S DAD'S ESTATE
BEFORE HE PASSING.
BUT HE WENT ON TV TO GET THE
BOOSTER SHOT.
>> NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT IT.
[SCREAMING].
OH, IT BURNS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> Greg: THAT DIDN'T GO OVER TOO
WELL.
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD HEAR HER
OUTDOOR VOICE.
JUDGE JEANINE!
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
HE'S GIVEN US MORE GREAT SINGLES
THAN A SEARCH ON MATCH.COM.
LARRY GATLIN.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Laura: STAND BY YOUR MAN
BEFORE SHE MOVES HIM INTO
TRAFFIC.
KAT TIMPF.
>> Greg: HE IS SO HUGE HIS
FLIGHT LANDED AT 3:05 P.M. AT
3:06 P.M. -- TYRUS.
HOW IS IT GOING JUDGE?
>> I AM DOING OKAY.
>> Greg: THAT LEOPARD IS DEAD
BUT HAPPY HE DIED FOR THIS.
>> HE DIED FOR YOU AND EVERYBODY
HERE.
I AM THIS NASHVILLE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> Greg: STOP GOING FOR THE EASY
APPLAUSE.
THAT'S WHAT I DO.
GREAT TO BE IN NASHVILLE.
SHOULDN'T LEADERS SET AN EXAMPLE
AND EMBRACE RESPONSIBILITY?
WHAT IS GOING WITH OUR
PRESIDENT?
>> NOTHING.
HOW CAN HE SET AN EXAMPLE.
I CALL HIM THE LIAR AND CHIEF.
HE SAID THERE WAS NO REAL
VACCINE.
NOBODY WAS VACCINATED WHEN HE
GOT THERE.
THERE WERE 3 VACCINES WERE MOVED
AT WARP SPEED BY DONALD TRUMP.
THERE WAS A PLAN.
THERE WAS A PLAN IN AFGHANISTAN.
THE MAN IS OUT OF HIS MIND.
HE HAS NO IDEA WHAT REALITY IS
OR WAREALITY IS.
I REPEATED MYSELF.
>> Greg: YOU DID.
IT BEARS REPEATING.
LOSERS AND LIBERALS AND LIARS
AND LEAKERS.
>> SAY IT RIGHT.
LIARS, LEAKERS AND LIBERALS.
>> Greg: LARRY CAN YOU IMAGINE
DOING THIS AT WORK IF YOU WORK.
YOU SAY IT'S THE OTHER GUYS
FAULT.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL?
IT'S GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> GREAT TO SEE YOU.
>> Greg: I LIKE YOUR SHIRT.
>> THANK YOU.
CAN YOU SEE UNDER IT?
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT I AM
TALKING ABOUT.
YOU ARE APPLAUDING A RACIST
SHIRT.
>> I WILL ANSWER YOUR QUESTION.
A GREAT SONG WRITER WROTE THIS
SONG MANY YEARS AGO.
YELLOW, BLACK OR WHITE, THEY ARE
PRECIOUS IN HIS SIGHT.
JESUS LOVES THE LITTLE CHILDREN
OF THE WORLD.
>> WHERE AM I?
>> Greg: YOU ARE EATING INTO
YOUR TALK TIME.
YOU ONLY HAVE ONE POINT AND IT
HAS TO BE A REAL GOOD ONE.
>> WE ALL KNOW ABOUT ALL OF THE
THINGS THE JUDGE WAS TALKED
ABOUT.
HOW MANY OF YOU FATHERS, MOTHERS
AND GRANDMOTHERS AND GRAND
FATHERS WOULD GIVE THE KEYS OF
YOUR CAR AND HOUSE TO PROTECT
YOUR KIDS, GRANDKIDS AND ONE DOG
WHILE YOU WENT ON VACATION FOR 2
DAYS TO FLORIDA?
IF YOU WOULD DO THAT, SAY YEAH?
IF YOU WOULD NOT SAY NO.
>> NO!
>> HE HAS THE KEYS TO THE
NUCLEAR FOOTBALL.
>> Greg: KAT, DO YOU THINK BIND
WILL BUILD ANYTHING BACK BETTER?
>> NO.
COMPLAINING DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
EVERYONE INHERITS A MESS.
ISN'T THAT WHAT MARRIAGE IS?
MY HUSBAND INHERIT AID MESS.
I HAVE BEEN BURNED IN THE PAST
AND HAVE ISSUES.
HE DOESN'T COMPLAIN.
HE KNOWS HE IS LUCKY TO BE
MARRIED TO A NATURAL TREASURE.
>> [CHEERS AND APPLAUSE].
>> THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO COMPLAIN
ABOUT IT ARE MODERN POLITICIANS.
IT'S NOT LIKE LINCOLN COMPLAINED
ABOUT THE MESS HE INHERITED
ABOUT THE CIVIL WAR.
THIS IS NOT MY FAULT.
DON'T BLAME ME.
HE FOCUSSED ON BRINGING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND SOLUTIONS TO
PROBLEMS AND NOT MAKING ABOUT IT
HIMSELF.
THAT'S WHAT A LEADER IS SUPPOSED
TO DO.
>> Greg: IF JOE BIDEN WERE
ACTUALLY PRESIDENT I WOULD NOT
WORRY AS MUCH BUT HE IS JUST
A HOOD ORNAMENT TO A DANGEROUS
WOKE MACHINE.
WE HAVE TO CHECK UNDER THE HOOD.
>> YOU GO AHEAD.
I DON'T HAVE TO LOOK UNDER THE
HOOD TO KNOW THE ENGINE IS GONE.
COULD WE PLEASE PUT THE GREG
SMURF UP.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
I THOUGHT THERE WAS NOT MUCH
PHOTO SHOP IN THERE.
>> Greg: I WAS TALLER IN THAT
PICTURE.
>> YES.
THERE IT IS.
THAT'S MAGIC.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S RIGHT UP THERE WITH
THINKING THAT PRESIDENT BIDEN
KNOWS WHAT IS GOING ON.
A BETTER CHANCE OF THAT SMURF
BALANCING THE BUDGET THAN
ANYTHING GOING ON IN THE OFFICE.
>> Greg: CAN YOU IMAGINE WAKING
UP TO THAT SITTING ON YOUR
CHEST?
>> IT YOU